hey man how are you how you doing
nothing makes sense anymore are you okay
Daisy broke up I won't even eat Chiana
oh god that's the cutest ever seen in my
life why'd your door open I'm sorry Oh
sup sup bro here cuz my place got broken
into does anyone shady come by here I
mean there's 17 three Clips brought it
17 street let's just go check it out
what's the worse that can happen one
beer please I'll take a white wine
spritzer what you can't talk like that
here then we really are in trouble
because you sound like Sean Ritter all
the top row AA big to differ went
straight to the N word in a wide place
there with a boy push this crazy drug
dealer gawky on we in the market right
now for like a gangster pet
uriage what do you think my idea phone
was why are you talking to me like that
I talk like that sometimes
okk amo
this must [ __ ] right here
what's the horse that can happen one
beer please I'll take a white wine
spritzer claire's what you can't talk
like that here then we really are in
trouble because you sound like John
Ritter all the time